[Musique]
je me souviens de la ryder cup en fait
de deux ryder cup de deux moments de
moments ces riders capa médina mehdi l'a
donc aux états unis en fait ce qui se
passe
départ de doubler dans les doubles en
fait vous savez dans le golfe
il ya toujours au moment où c'est comme
au tennis au moment où le joueur sert au
golf c'est au moment où il va taper sa
balle il ya toujours un silence on
entend les mouches tournée et en fait je
sais pas ce qui prend à yanbu pas et ian
poulter ian poulter au lieu d'avoir ce
silence sur départ du trou numéro un
dont le voit un petit peu se retourner
vers la foule faire des mouvements et en
fait qui demandait c'était à la foule le
faire de plus en plus de bruit et long
que c'était génial parce qu'on avait
vous aviez autour du départ je sais pas
te fais dix mille spectateurs qui
hurlait fit chanter crier us puisque
c'était plutôt de de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique et donc là donc
ian poulter qui tape le coup en face
bien évidemment avec ip américaine n'a
pas voulu rester là dessus et donc bubba
watson a fait exactement la même chose
c'est-à-dire a motivé la foule de façon
de faire de plus en plus de bruit de
plus en plus de plus en plus c'est donc
là c'était exactement pareil réellement
ce moment là c'est pareil à queue dans
la ryder cup où on peut avoir des
moments aussi aussi atypique
exceptionnel ceux ci avaient été
renouvelés à gleneagles sur la ryder cup
de 2014 ou bubba watson
avait demandé au public écossais de fer
est normalement de bruit au moment où
vous tapez sa balle et dans les journaux
il était étonné parce que il s'attendait
à avoir un peu de monde qu'elle et
l'encourager et ce moment là pour moi ça
a été
c'est un moment un moment inoubliable et
exceptionnelle parce que pareil c'est
beaucoup d'émotion et les choses voilà
atypique exceptionnel qu'on ne trouvera
que sur une ryder cup
[Musique]